y el hecho de que la canciller alemana
angela merkel haya interrumpido su
agenda en washington donde está en una
visita oficial probablemente la última
visita a eeuu como canciller para hablar
de las devastadoras inundaciones en el
occidente de alemania demuestra la
urgencia de lo que está ocurriendo aquí
en este país además de expresar su
solidaridad la canciller angela merkel
explicó que está en contacto no
solamente con las autoridades regionales
de las zonas más afectadas sino también
con los ministros de finanzas y del
interior para coordinar exactamente como
el gobierno federal se vinculará a las
ayudas no solamente en el tema inmediato
del rescate sino también más adelante en
la reconstrucción
angela merkel también hizo énfasis en
que ha recibido mensajes de otros
colegas europeos en señal de solidaridad
y de hecho la presidenta de la comisión
europea úrsula fondo online emitió un
comunicado en el que explica que la
unión europea está dispuesta a ayudar a
alemania ya otros países europeos que se
han visto afectados por estas
inundaciones